[Música]
olá meu nome é minha
e hoje eu vou apresentar sobre um tema
muito interessante mas antes disso eu
vou contar uma curiosidade
vocês sabiam que é que nesse momento o a
cada dia a cada hora alguém pode estar
morrendo por causa da guerra ou porque
nunca teve uma vida muito feliz em
entrar e é isso que nós vamos discutir
esse tema é primeiro cinema de shopping
vocês vão descobrir no meio da
apresentação
mas qual foi a contribuição dele com o
mundo
nós vamos descobrir essas são muitas em
países em que ele crítico mas preste
atenção será que essas pessoas estão
vivendo b
será que não
nós vamos descobrir ao longo de sua
apresentação como é que poderá ser
mudada de chapín foi o homem que
conseguiu mudar uma parte da população e
que por medo da sua arte conseguiu
causar muito sorriso das pessoas e esse
é que foi um lugar onde ele viveu na
durante sua infância mas o lugar é zii
bem pra você saber em que lugar é esse
que eu vou contar lugar foi isso
esse foi o lugar onde abrigou e ele
quando ele era ainda bem pequeno porque
ele virou orla por causa que o pai ele
era alcoólatra e acabou morrendo muito
cedo ea mãe como tinha um problema
mental acabou sendo internada no brasil
que também teve que ficar em dois
orfanatos conseguir viver e essa aqui é
uma cena de um dos filmes dele o tempo
os tempos modernos onde ele critica a
revolução industrial que fuma água que
causa muito impacto na inglaterra e
também em outros países
e essa aqui é a cena original
e você sabe de uma coisa
enquanto o soldado na segunda guerra não
tinha mais
capacidade de lutar sabe que onde o
disco que eles faziam bem ele seguiu
para a enfermaria e acabam vendo filmes
de arte teatro pra ficarem mais felizes
e essa aqui é uma imagem do filme a
criança que critica pobreza e também
quem mostra em que mesmo nos momentos em
que você não consegue fazer nada você
você sempre vai ter uma luz no final do
túnel
e essa imagem do chefe com o menino que
então o filme a criança onde ele cuida
de um menino que foi abandonado na rua e
esses ataques aos filhos dos filmes que
causaram muito impacto na sociedade
antiga o primeiro uso da cidade que foi
história em que o shopping ele é o
vagabundo que é o homem que no que não é
rico que há sim uma crítica aos homens
da sociedade antiga que tinha um que
usava roupas antigas que tinham roupas
esfarrapadas bengalas um pouco mais
simples onde ele odiava ele tenta
conquistar o amor de uma força recebe
acaba falando que o bilionário e ela
acaba acreditando e outro é achar
shopping
a corrida do ouro o capitão de
inglaterra que pegar mais dinheiro fora
do país
e então ele critica a ganância dos
homens e último o grande ditador que é
que o filme que ele critica o nazismo e
também ao mesmo tempo a guerra que na
hora de ponta uma biografia do ditador
kim que eu quero um soldado e depois
mais pra frente viu o ditado da alemanha
foi basicamente o que aconteceu com
hitler
então pra você ver o que que foi meu deu
a agora é hora das perguntas luz câmera
e ação o que acelerou de charlie chaplin
pra vocês é só uma obra de arte
representa uma inovação do cinema antigo
transmitir mensagens para o mundo
provoca riso mesmo no momento de
tristeza é engraçado mas não se viu uma
mensagem
sei de resposta certa boas escolhas
então com isso tem muito obrigado
[Aplausos]